right so today I'm gonna talk about okay
so welcome back everyone from the coffee
break and so this is the last talk of
the day and of the workshop so we're
very happy to have if Lamia from the
University of Sydney before he starts
let me remind everyone in case you just
joined that you should feel free to
interrupt Steve with questions there's
different ways you can do that you can
just speak up or you can use the chat or
you can use the Q&A and I and the other
panelists would be modern monitoring
that so don't hesitate the welcome steel
and series on the first about work with
Robin Harper Joel Waldman when turn you
on efficiently estimating Polly
challenge okay so go ahead
okay thanks tomorrow so I'm gonna talk
about efficiently estimating power
channels as he said this is joint work
with Robin Harper Joel Waldman and when
June you two of the three papers are on
the archive already and so I'll start by
is my slide updating doesn't look like
it's updating no way dude so I'm Tina
okay no it did not
okay now okay I think it's working out
okay yep so I will paraphrase two whole
stoy and say that noiseless quantum
computers are all alike but every noisy
quantum computer is a noisy in its own
way so if we have ideal qubits we sort
of know what we want to do with them we
don't I'm gonna read the whole story but
we have a ton of great ideas and it's
easy to think about what we're gonna do
with them because we don't have to worry
about noise but when we have to worry
about noise there's a lot of different
ways study noisy quantum device can fail
you can have coherent errors you know
lost errors you got correlated errors
you can have time-dependent errors and
so that's what I mean by everything
noisy quantum computer is no easy in its
own way
and so we would love to be able to
characterize general noise on an any
cubic quantum Channel if you know this
is kind of an essential task if we want
to build a large-scale quantum computer
but unfortunately it's also intractable
and so if we want to make this a
tractable learning problem learning
something about noise we have to
introduce some sort of assumptions we
have to make in this talk we'll focus on
is introducing structural assumptions
into the noise in order to make learning
of general channels tractable and before
I get to those structural assumptions I
want to make a rough dichotomy and
consider two classes of noise and you
should consider this to be heuristic
because it's sort of difficult to give
you to precisely cleave the set of noise
into two halves like this but roughly
speaking I'm going to consider coherent
and incoherent noise sources so a
coherent noise source might be I'm
trying to do my one or two qubit gate
and I have a slight over or under
rotation but I don't have any loss an
incoherent noise source might be I leak
into some unobservable degree of freedom
which is an infinite size bat so those
you know that never comes back or maybe
I have I apply something like a power
channel with a phasing channel amplitude
damping channel these are all examples
of incoherent noise channels okay
coherent noise is nice in the following
sense if I could diagnose it and
characterize it it can in principle be
calibrated away but at some point this
becomes impractical reason if I have a
many body rotation just writing down a
description of that many body rotation
might be intractably large so at some
point diagnosing and adjusting for these
from hearing noise sources I mean at
some point a quantum computer that's all
it is doing is engineering a specific
linear quotation so there are kind of
limits to how much coherent noise we can
remove from a device just by
characterizing it because at some point
in order to do that here's kind of
assuming the existence of a
fault-tolerant quantum computer in order
to do those operations this talk instead
is about incoherent noise and in
particular I'm going to focus on Palli
channels and there are several good
reasons to focus on paui channels and
the first is that this is the most
relevant noise model for quantum error
correction and fault tolerance so if you
have detailed knowledge of a Palli noise
channel also you can dramatically
improve quantum error correcting code
performance so together with former PhD
student of mine Sidney David Tucket we
showed in a few different papers were
not the only ones other people have
shown as well if I use this pointer does
that appear okay yet great that you know
the the threshold shows large
improvements if you have certain types
of incoherent noise in your system if
you characterize that and then you adapt
your code and your decoder to deal with
that specific norms so that's one reason
to consider a coherent noise channel
channels another one is that we now have
tools that can project a noise channel
into its poly approximation so once
you've given up on characterizing
incoherent noise sorry coherent noise
sources then what I can do is I can
assume and then enforce that assumption
to a high degree of accuracy that the
noise is in fact incoherent these are
tools like dynamical decoupling that
remove time like correlations and
polyframe randomization and randomize
compiling that actually enforce the poly
approximation and lastly quantum error
correction seems to make noise less
coherent so if you're encoding into a
quantum error correcting code and you're
asking about the noise in the logical
channel there is now there are now
several papers that suggest that the
noise at the logical level is less
coherent than it was originally so that
means if we're interested in
characterizing noise at the logical
level which someday soon we will
it's good to have well-developed
protocols that's better tailored to take
advantage of incoherent noise oh and
here's an experiment if you don't
believe me here's data from an
experiment that was done in a
superconducting qubit out of BBN and
what they did is they had some
incoherent sorry they had some coherent
noise in their device you're seeing a
picture of the super operator noise map
of their quantum channel and then they
introduced polyframe randomization and
randomized compiling into their into
their setup to project the channel
they're just averaging over the power
group basically when they do that they
can project the channel into the I've
written out this channel in the Poway
basis I can project it onto its diagonal
elements and all of these off diagonal
elements are so small that they're
within the statistical error bars so we
can actually enforce the the
approximation that channel is a power
channel okay I've talked a lot about
encoding hear noise but I haven't
actually defined what is a power channel
so I think it would be good if I do that
a power channel it's just a convex
combination of the action of a poly
operator on your state where these P sub
K are called the pally error rates and
capital P sub K those are the power
operators so that's all it is and this
is a probability distribution over four
to the N elements in general when you're
talking about an N cubed power channel
this representation that I've written
over here is called the super operator
representation and if I write the super
operator representation in the Pala
basis it's a property of all power
channels that they are diagonal in that
basis the diagonal elements of this
matrix are called the channel
eigenvalues I might slip up and call
them poly fidelities but I was told by
referees that I shouldn't do that
she's just call them eigenvalues because
that's what they are they're the
eigenvalues of the channel the
eigenvalues of the power channel okay
and I'm going to denote those lambda
okay
right so the first step in this talk is
to go from general quantum channels and
then appeal to these other results about
things like dynamical decoupling and
randomized compiling to argue that we
can focus our interests on a special
class of channels which are general poly
channels but as I also said there are
four to the N elements in a probability
distribution a general of a general
Talley Channel so this is going to still
be intractable we've reduced a problem
of about 16 to the end parameters for
general quantum noise to one of the four
to the end so this is an improvement but
it's not big enough that's when the
structural assumptions come in and
that's going to be this the latter half
of this talk so the first thing I'm
going to do is address general poly
channels and we're going to use those
ideas as a subroutine to learn something
about structured power channels and the
two types of structures that I'm going
to consider our s sparse poly channels
and bounded degree correlated power
channels so these are by that I mean I'm
going to model the poly channel as a
Markov network and I'm going to assume a
Markovian property that if I have a
probability distribution over subsets of
qubits P a and B and C and are
conditioned on C or C as a separating
subset than those probabilities in the
Power Distribution factorized okay
that's going to be my structural
assumption and then I'm going to assume
that the factor graph is bounded degree
that if I think you didn't follow that
I'll return to that a little bit later
and we're going to see that in these two
cases under fairly mild and plausible
physical assumptions this is a tractable
learning problem okay so let me just
overview the main theoretical results
I'm also going to show experimental data
and this talk as well so the first
result is for learning a general and
cubic power Channel and the number of
measurements required scales like n
times 2 to the N divided by epsilon
squared in order to get a relative
precision estimate of the list of Palli
error probabilities so in this
expression P
is an estimate of the for to the end the
link for to the end vector of poly error
probabilities P is the true answer
there's some constant sitting in front
and the closer the error channel is to
the ideal error channel so this means
the channel supported only on the no
error channel so the more your poly air
channel the closer your panel error
channel gets to an ideal channel with no
noise at all the better this error
guarantee performs so this relative
error guarantee is crucial in
applications where you're talking about
error rates 10 to the minus 3 end of the
lattice for I think the record is error
rates of or 10 to the minus 6 or
something like this you know if this was
a sampling limited algorithm you would
have to do 10 to the 12 samples to even
distinguish an error rate of 10 to the
minus 6 from 0 so having this relative
guarantee is a really nice feature of
this algorithm most people
yeah you know how does this tune on
translate as a norm on the channel does
it go to time no more so this is wrong
yes it depends how you define the norm
of the channel so I can map is also in
the to a guarantee in the diamond
distance or to the Hilbert norm of the
difference between the channel and the
true I mean that's actually kind of what
this is if I if I take the super
operator matrix and I look at the
Hilbert norm of the difference that's
exactly what this is you lose the
dimensional factor I think and if you
directly bring this over to the diamond
distance I have to look at my paper in
to remember the exact statement but
isn't that what you want Indian like
because what would you yes I yeah maybe
um if you want to incorporate that in
and absorb it into epsilon that's you
know going to change
you'd have to rescale epsilon and you're
gonna get a worse scaling here I mean
you can't for a general and cubed
channel you can't
an exponential stealing I don't think I
haven't proven that but you I don't
think you can be an exponential scaling
but the constants here are such that
this works really quite well in practice
so yeah the only way that I know to get
a guaranteeing the diamond distance is
to do some naive dimensional factor I
don't have a direct analysis of the
diamond distance that would be
interesting but I'll show some data we
can run this on 14 cubed channels then
we get very good performance so like the
the the constants are really quite
favorable and this isn't a scalable
protocol as it stands so you're going to
need to it's kind of important that the
constants are good because then we're
going to use it as a subroutine later on
them maybe that answers your question I
hope that answered your question yeah
thanks okay Eve this is Robin quick
question isn't so the bounds between two
norm and diamond norm for an arbitrary
channel are really bad they've got that
dimension factor in them isn't it a lot
I think it's d the dimension of the
Hilbert space I think it's another
factor of to the N but I would need to
open up my paper and double-check but
isn't it better for a poly channel yes
but
it is much better for a poly channel
it's a constant I don't need to think
about I can't answer the question
without looking at my paper again you're
just reach oh you've had it open on the
side since I'm giving this talk on zoom
and that way I can look like I remember
every minor detail this 30-something
page paper I think there's a reason why
we needed the dimensional factor but I
could be wrong you're absolutely right
about what you said there Robin so now
I'm a little confused but I can try to
answer this question if I J if I just
can look through my paper again the
other two main Theory results if I have
an S sparse channel on n qubits then I
can learn that channel again to relative
precision epsilon using order s times
and measurements of how the eigenvalues
and this is a new results that's
unpublished with whinging you we had
some other results in my paper with Joel
Waldman they had it was better in some
parameters worse than other parameters
but when we coded it up overall at least
our implementation of it it wasn't
particularly practical this new one is
more practical to constants and and all
it performs better so I'm not going to
mention the original work which is in
this paper I am going to mention this
newer one and then the last one is if
you have a degree K Markov field Palais
channel you can learn an N cubed such
channel in time polynomial in n using N
squared log n measurements and there's a
pre factor that depends exponentially on
K and now the guarantee that we get is
actually in the one norm on the
probability distribution not in the two
norm so you actually get a stronger
guarantee and it's because up here
although the natural protocol for
estimating power channels that we get
gives us guarantees and the two norm we
can leverage that to get over all the
little clusters
are correlated I look at all the
marginal error rates on all the reduced
channels of all those clusters and I get
a two norm guarantee on each of them
using this as a subroutine and then when
I piece them together I get a relative
guarantee in the one norm so it's quite
nice that we get a guarantee on the
global and Cuba channel in the one norm
M which is easier to translate into the
diamond norm that's where the now I'm
remembering the one norm is directly
related to the diamond norm not the two
norm that answers both of these
questions so in order to get from the
two norm to the diamond norm I have to
go through the only way I know how to do
it about the other one norm and then you
lose a dimensional factor but when we do
the mark off field we don't have to pay
that price because of some magic okay
whoops
right and as I stressed this is all
results to relative precision and so
what's nice about these results is that
we can derive them under we can drive
them rigorously under some pretty
clearly stated assumptions on the
physics so the first is that the noise
on the gates that we're applying in this
set of circuits that we're going to
implement is independent of the choice
of pally that we're implementing so this
is the gate independent noise assumption
we're quite confident that this
assumption can be relaxed using some
ideas by Wallman and Merkel perch
pretended fall but we haven't done that
work the other is that the noise
distribution is time stationary so the
distribution is time shift invariant so
the noise is sampled from the same
distribution and every time equivalently
we're estimating like the DC offset of
the noise so we're not considering time
variation you could also consider time
variation you could try to do a
time-resolved version of this protocol
but we don't analyze that and the last
one is that the noise is Markovian so in
particular the noise is described by
completely positive Maps you could
imagine more exotic behavior we don't
analyze that and then there's two other
technical assumptions that we need just
to get a well-conditioned estimator but
I don't
think that these are necessary for our
proof technique but I don't think that
they're in any way fundamental the first
is that the gate the noise on the gates
is not too far from the identity in
practice that means that I can allow
error probabilities as large as half and
that the measurements are not too noisy
so again as long as your measurement
returns the correct answer half the time
then you're okay so those are just
technical assumptions oops
okay so let me describe what the
circuits are that we own oh do my ok I
think I just froze my screening in
[Music]
trying a new setup so okay you have to
do that a couple more times this slides
a little bit busy I took this figure
from my paper with Robin Harper and Joel
Waldman this one down here so the
circuits that we run are similar to
circuits that have been written down
previously by other authors so we're
going to in these papers in particular
what we're going to do is we're going to
prepare some states and we're going to
do a long sequence of single qubit
either Clifford or Polly gates in the
actual in the protocol that we analyze
we put Polly's here but you can also do
Clifford's and in this paper we do the
Clifford version so I'm just doing PI D
each red box is an iid random Clifford
gate and I'm going to do that n times
for some parameter m and then I'm going
to invert that sequence and then I'm
going to measure the bit string that I
get at the end and I can also do this in
like a two qubit mode where I do pairs
of clippers if I want to coarse-grain
some of the correlations or if I want to
learn about the two qubit gates that
have something that this protocol
doesn't yet do is I'm not we don't
interleave another gate to learn about a
specific gate although it should be
straightforward to extend it to that
case but we haven't done that so I'm
going to run these circuits for a bunch
of different values of M and I'm gonna
measure these bit strings so I'm gonna
count how many times that I get spin-up
or spin-down
these are n bit measurements that are
reading out and so on this axis here is
different values of M equals one two
four eight so on with like an
exponential spacing because we're
interested in long sequences because the
long sequences is what's going to give
us the relative precision so if we make
a very short circuit here with M equals
one then most of the time I wind up back
in the state that I started in but
occasionally I'm going to see some
errors and these are the counts of a
real experiment that we did that I'm
going to return to later at the talk but
if I do longer sequences it's less
likely that I get back to where I
started even though in the ideal case
this circuit is actually the
identity it should it should return you
right back to the state that you started
in so now for each one of these slices
I'm going to take this list of numbers
and I'm gonna do a Walsh Hadamard
transform this is the transform that you
need to do to transform between the
description of the poly channel in terms
of the poly error probabilities and the
eigenvalues of the poly channel so now
what I have is a list of probability
vectors each one of these is a label for
a poly error probability but I'm
conflating the noise on the measurements
with each of these estimates here okay
and I have M of them one for each of
sorry I have them indexed by air it
shouldn't say there's an M probability
vectors it's just one for each value of
n that I chose each circuit length and
so for each of these if I follow one row
for example if I look at the second
element here the Palais channel and I
look at the different n values and I
plot them on these axes like this so
this is the first value of M the second
the third the fourth and so on I'm going
to observe an exponential decay so this
is on a log plot so what we see when we
do a plot of just this row and we plot
along M we observe an exponential decay
and we can actually derive that we
derived that in our paper and I get that
for each row of these of this array this
is like think of this as a
two-dimensional array indexed by Polly's
on this axis and by circuit lengths on
the other axis so for every pally when I
plot it as a function of n I get
exponential decay and so now I can do I
can fit a line to this on log axes and
the slope of that line tells me what the
error probability is for that specific
Palli error rate and so now I'm sorry it
tells me the Pelle eigen value tells me
the eigen value of the channel this is a
recipe for computing channel eigen
values so then I can take this list of
Palais channel eigen values by
estimating the
slope what I've done is I've removed the
contribution and the noise of the
measurement errors that I've isolated
the contribution to the noise with the
gates right so the measurements are
going to change the offset of this the
actual error rates as given by this
channel I can value determine the slope
and then the slope is insensitive you
may need more sampling to observe the
same slope if you have low contrast but
you can still get it and then one more
Walsh Hadamard transform gets me back to
a list of all the error probabilities of
this power channel in a way that's spam
free we also have to do one additional
post-processing step to project it onto
the simplex to get a true probability
distribution okay so that's a whirlwind
overview of how this algorithm works and
here it is with some numerical simulated
data so so this is a four cubed poly
channel that I simulated on my laptop
let me see how I'm doing for time okay
and you can see an orange here are a
list of true poly error rates in the
simulation listed in decreasing order
and the blue dots are the ones that are
reconstructed by sampling from this
channel only 200,000 times which is
pretty feasible with existing existing
hardware at least in things like
superconductors or ion traps little
harder than ion traps because their
clock speed is slow and here's the same
data plotted with respect to the oh that
should say lambda these are the channel
eigenvalues these are the error
probabilities so it works well in
practice
I'm just going to skip that okay so let
me talk about sparse family channels now
so I mentioned that we can estimate an s
sparse power Channel much more
efficiently using s x and total
measurements and the computation time is
quadratic it takes about s times N
squared amount of classical computation
in order to produce this estimate
I think it might be possible using ideas
from FFTs to speed this up and get it
almost linear in n but we don't have
that result we do have this result it's
a few and the guarantee is robust if I
don't have an actually a sparse channel
but I have a little bit of a tail oh did
it freeze again
I don't know various if I don't have an
actually as sparse channel but I look at
the if I look at the difference from the
best s sparse approximation that I'm
always going to make a model error and
that's unavoidable we can get an error
guarantee which has a relative error
plus a model error which is the ideal
constant here would be one and we can't
achieve that as part of our analysis but
we just pick up whatever the model there
or tail is time some constant factor we
can I can either grow bust in that sense
maybe not optimally but close so this
scaling is really close to close to
optimal if you haven't work I mean just
labeling s different errors in an N
cubed system requires n bits to label
each of the s errors so this is kind of
close to optimal and I'm just gonna give
a very quick sketch I don't have to lift
your sorry you know I have a question I
tried to ask it didn't go through
so this scaling is assuming that you
know a priori what are the nonzero terms
so you know that oh no no sorry that's
right they're completely unknown and I
don't necessarily have to know what s is
because you could try to dynamically
learn s as well you could say I'm gonna
try it with s equals 100 and then try it
again M at s equals 200 and see if my
estimate changes and you know with log s
queries you could pretty quickly figure
out what s is and we don't need
know what the subset of size s of
nonzero error rates is in order to use
this method so and it works for
arbitrary subsets it doesn't just have
to be only the low weight errors so if
you have some process that's causing a
highway error for some reason this will
detect it Thanks okay and the idea is to
do a special kind of subsampling so I'm
gonna give a toy example this is not a
real example because I don't have time
to go through the details of a real
example sadly suppose that I have a poly
channel and there's only four nonzero
error rates then because the
relationship between the poly error
rates and the channel eigenvalues is a
linear map it's the Walsh Hadamard
transform there's a linear relationship
between I can I can identify which
channel eigenvalues contain which
nonzero poly error rates okay and you
know that map the Walsh Hadamard
transform is a dense unitary matrix
consisting of all ones and zeros start
ones and minus ones but when I apply it
to a sparse vector then the you know the
output is only going to involve sparse
linear combinations okay and so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to subsample
okay I'm gonna throw away large chunks
of the channel and I'm gonna sub sample
a small stack of poly eigenvalues of
this channel that are going to contain
certain linear combinations so for
example I'm gonna I'm gonna hash
everything and I'm gonna find that in
the sub sample group one of channel
eigen values that I estimate may be the
first eigenvalue only contains p1 this
box is empty this box contains a sum of
two nonzero eigen values I don't know
what these sums are in here because
they're hidden from me but I'm opening
up the box to show you what's happening
under the hood and maybe this one has
one in it and then I'm going to pick a
second hash fruit and in general I'm
going to pick a constant number of
hashes in which
been these linear combinations of poly
error rates associated and then I'm
going to estimate each of these channel
I give values in each of the sub sampled
groups okay that's the protocol okay and
if I can estimate these and they're
sparse and then if I can do one other
further thing so suppose I also had an
Oracle that could do the following
suppose I had an Oracle that said I can
identify that this bin here has exactly
one nonzero poly error rate in it if I
had that then what I could do is I could
do something like the following I could
subtract p1 from this bin and from every
other bin that it appears in inside this
graph right I could just do that I could
identify this and I could say I know
that there's only one in it and I know
that p1 is the only thing that gets
hashed into this bin and now I can
subtract that from everything that
touches this node I can delete this node
from this graph and now my graph just
got sparser okay and if I iterate this
right so now I call the Oracle again and
this time I learned that p2 this is a p2
which is a singleton now so I can delete
this I can subtract this and now I can
delete p2 from this graph and now
everything is a singleton so I can
delete everything and I've learned all
the poly error rates with this method ok
so but I don't have such an Oracle but I
can do something which is close to that
by doing a type of aliasing so I can run
some additional I can do and I meant to
animate this but I I fail to do so
before the talks started I can do an
alias thing where I changed this plus
sign to a minus sign and if I do that I
can check whether or not that specific
bin changed its magnitude or not and if
I can do that then I can check whether
or not a bin has more than one poly
aerated it if after a bunch of aliasing
I never see any change it's always just
empty then I have high confidence that
it's an empty bin if all I ever see are
sign changes and I have high confidence
that it's a singleton thing okay so if
it ever changes its magnitude I can test
that it's got more that it's got more
than one thing in it I can test its if
it's empty
or if it's absolute value stays the same
I can test that it's a singleton and if
I can do that robustly yeah so sorry I
forgot to keep up with my bullet points
if I can do that robustly then we can
prove that this idea of peeling we can
appeal to the fact that these hash
functions will give us an expander
geometry and then this is like decoding
a sparse error correcting code at that
point so this decoding procedure if I
just iterate it is going to peel off all
these pins that I've identified with
high probability and then I can learn
all the s sparse error rates of this
channel okay let me pause for a second
and ask if there are any questions about
sparse error reconstruction whoops yeah
it was pretty quick okay and then the
next the last theoretical result that I
want to talk about is the Markov graph
reconstruction so what is a Markov
network so if I have a probability
distribution over a list of random
variables X 1 X 2 X 3 X 4 so these are
going to be whether or not Palli by X Y
or Z appears on let's say the first
qubit I'm going to assume that this
probability distribution factorizes in
the following way into a product of
positive functions that depend only on
the subset of the variables together
with some normalizing factor or
partition function if you're a physicist
and this factorization I can write this
factorization using something called a
factor graph so here I have two factors
c1 and c2 c1 is connected to x1 x2 and
x3 so I'm going to write a factor down
for that factor and these are like I
said are very positive functions now if
I change the factor graph I can get a
finer or a coarser factorization that
I'm assuming for this probability
distribution so here now I've introduced
four factors see one two three and four
and now I have a much more stringent
factorization where everything inside
the factorization depends only on two
variables at a time okay so that's the
idea of a factor graph these things are
called factor potentials we assume
they're strictly positive and we're also
going to use a couple basic definitions
from network topology the boundary the
other set and the closure of a set so
what do I mean by that here's an example
if x1 is a set of random variables then
the boundary is going to be all the
things that I can reach in terms of two
steps on this bipartite graph so my
thing is updating so if x1 is a set then
neighborhood it would be X two and three
because I can reach X two via the first
factor and I can reach X 3 via the
second factor I think my you screen or
there it is
ok good yeah so the blue is the set and
then this is its boundary because I can
go like this this isn't working super
well I can go like that or like that to
reach those two so they are in this set
I may have to hopefully that's working
again mmm I think my screen is freezing
again you know let me just try to go to
my desktop for a second go back sorry
about this
okay hopefully that's beautiful again
it's just got a bad delay okay right so
um there's two types of nodes and these
factor graphs the factor nodes and the
variable nodes in the examples that I'm
going to give in the rest of the talk if
I don't explicitly draw a factor node
somewhere in the graph I'm just gonna it
just means that I'm only considering two
local factors okay so if I just draw a
graph that the factor is implicit by the
edge okay um for this talk I'm going to
assume that I know this graph structure
in advance if I don't know the graph
structure in advance then you're doing
something called structure learning um
we also have some unpublished work about
structure learning that we're developing
but I don't have time to talk about it
so I'm just going to assume that the
graph structure is known a priori okay
so to illustrate so now what I want to
do is just estimate the parameters given
the network topology
that's my sole goal so I'm going to
estimate each local joint distribution
of Palli errors on its node and all of
its neighbors in this example so for
example I have let's say the cubit in
the upper left it's neighborhood its its
neighbors are these red dots and so the
closure is all three of them and I'm
going to use this original algorithm
that I wrote down that has exponential
scaling and I'm gonna learn the all the
pal a error rates in that neighborhood
okay and so as long as that neighborhood
has found a degree I can do this in
polynomial time because it will just be
a constant and then I'm going to loop
over all the nodes and all of their
neighborhoods and that's it I'm just
going to learn all the marginals but
this doesn't quite solved the problem
yet because this gives me a list of
marginals but now I have to round these
marginals into a global probability
distribution to get a consistent joint
description without that rounding are
just
a list of our journals and I'm doing
something closer to like shadow
tomography or something of low-weight
things I'm not getting no global
description okay shall I start shadow
estimation I want to actually do the
tomography I want to do the universe
step to get the full object that's the
goal okay and you're still paying
attention to this talk and probably it's
clear to you what I mean by rounding so
if I have I think I skipped a slide yeah
so if I have marginal distributions if I
have like a tripartite probability
distribution of some variables x y&z if
I marginalize the marginals over X Y if
i marginalize over X and I look at P of
Y or I marginalized P of Y said and then
I marginalized ever said either way I
get to P of Y right so this is just
properties of marginal distributions but
when there's noise that's no longer true
and I put a little happier and I have
noisy estimates then I have to have this
rounding step if I'm going to get a
consistent distribution okay when I do
this rounding step which I unfortunately
don't have to talk I don't have time to
talk about how we do the rounding then
this works really well so this is a
numerical simulation that I did for a
100 qubit chain with two qubit local
correlated noise and I fixed one I fixed
two hundred thousand samples for every
subset of qubits going down the chain
and then I reconstructed a global
probability distribution on one hundred
qubits in a factorized form that's how
we're able to write it down explicitly
so it takes the form of a tensor network
so I can store it efficiently on my
laptop and then I can compute things
like the two norm difference this is
called the Highlander difference this
distance it's like a fidelity this is
the relative entropy and I can plot how
these things scale when I fix the total
number of samples that I take on
a single marginal and it grows slowly
either like the square root or linearly
in the case of the relative entropy so
this really is polynomial time if I
wanted something that has absolute error
guarantees that's where I get this N
squared log n scaling because then I
don't want this to grow I want this to
stay flat beneath some big steps along
but the point is that I get really low
error rates using really practical
numbers with this idea okay so that's
all for the theory stuff I'm going to
talk about experiments next but I want
to pause to ask first if there are any
questions about the theory are there any
questions about theory
no doesn't appear that there are any
questions okay so if there's no
questions can you hear me yep yes I want
to quibble again about this distance
measure because your graphs you say
scalable inefficient and you write that
in large font but what it what you're
getting is a good approximation to this
to long distance again right and there
if you put the dimension for the mark
yeah so that a Markov channel for the
Markov one yeah so for this first one we
get a two norm guarantee is okay because
two and one would be related by a
function of this Marcy yeah but you have
to be careful because the sparsity is
technically an exponential variable
right even if I had independent noise on
each qubit of some low probability P
then I would expect to be able to
compress the channel into about two to
be H of P bits and H of P should be
extensive it should be linear in N and
you know that would be exponential but
with a very small prefactor so even in
the sparse case it's not obviously
scalable but the the constants are great
the constants are very good in the
Markov case we can leverage to norm
guarantees on constant size subsets with
the assumption that those are the only
sets that matter right that it's a
bounded degree factor graph well we can
leverage a two norm guarantee because
then I can get that in constant time
right and then I can get a one norm
guarantee on the whole channel and then
if it is indeed a poly channel or if I'm
doing this thing polyframe randomization
where I actively projected into the poly
projection of the channel then I am
getting a diamond distance guarantee
because the one arm in the dinah
distance are interchangeable if the
noise is a poly channel I guess you
didn't say that if you have on each of
your local channels in a Markov case you
have an estimate that has some error
let's say in the one one locally so how
does that arrow negation it's a
motorbike with a bi amplify it by taking
so let's do exponentially more samples
exponential decay which is fixed so
right right so let's do that so then how
does the air you know then you want to
global air when you do the
reconstruction so is that going to be
just adding up the local errors in the
best case it depends on the max it
depends on it turns out to depend on the
maximum of the local errors actually so
yeah we just need a max one more
guarantee and sorry a max two norm
guarantee on each of the local channels
and that's enough to give us a one norm
guarantee on the Markov field okay yeah
okay if there's no other questions does
anybody recognize this arc this is
lászló am i holding a guy it's called I
forget what it's called
Begg Brown told me about this painting
or these aren't paintings these are
ceramics ceramic tiles and the way that
the artist did this is they just called
up a factory and said can you please
create some tiles that look like the
following and then send them to me and
they said yeah sure you only want three
of them I guess we could do that and
sent them out to the artists and now
they're hanging in the Museum of Modern
Art and they're worth I don't know how
many millions of dollars so that brings
me so the experiments that I did and
more precisely Robin Harper dig and also
even more precisely some heroes in the
inside the salt mines at IBM that have
to tune up their devices every day
they're the ones doing the real end of
the experiments and I told Robin what to
do and Robin picked up the telephone and
then phoned in with the circuits where
they would monitor wrong so that's the
connection with that artwork okay so
this is the IBM device
we ran on a sixteen cubed device with
only 14 of the qubits operational at the
time that we ran the experiments and
this is the physical connectivity and we
assume that I'm going to skip this we
assume that we know the connectivity in
advance and we ran a variant of the
protocol that I talked about with
pallies where we we average over the
single qubit clifford group and since
I'm running low on time I'm gonna we get
a slightly coarser estimate of the noise
by doing this because we're averaging
over a larger group and there's some
interesting things to say about that but
I'm running a little bit long time so
I'm gonna skip over that and now let me
see if I can get this to work Oh No
please work
you
I have an animation that I wanna show
it's not loading though uh frustrating
yeah okay it's not updating again all
right let me I have an idea
you possibly can on the full-screen mode
maybe that's easier yeah I'm getting I'm
gonna try something different okay
can people see this we can see something
I don't know if it's this something yeah
I think we can say you can see my slides
again yeah okay so now this is an
animation which is hopefully playing for
everyone yes I'm looping over we we
actually did the experiment on 14 qubits
where we estimated two to the 14 course
framed Pelley error rates on being a
little bit big about how exactly they're
coarse-grained and here are all 2 to the
14 fits to that data set that we get so
you can see that every single one of
these fits this exponential decay fun so
it's really well and down on the right
hand side of this maybe you can also see
my mouse I can just play with my mouse
these are where each one corresponds to
as a channel eigen value so these slopes
are giving us the corresponding diagonal
channel the diagonal element at this
channel were channel agate value if it's
exactly a pilot channel okay so this is
real experimental data that we took on
this IBM device and using these data we
can do a lot of really interesting
things we can do things like construct a
correlation matrix to understand when
all the to local correlations are in
this device
so here are if I define a correlation
matrix based on an error is present or
absent on a given cubit and then I look
at the covariance matrix or in general
the correlation matrix which is
normalized so the way this plot works is
oops
the way this plot works is the each gray
square is 0 a white square that's the
size of one box is +1 a smaller white
square is the numerical value
proportional to its area and a black
square is a negative value proportional
to its area inside the crate a cell so
you can see that some of these errors
are correlated some of them are
anti-correlated and you can see a strike
going down the middle the the matrix is
sort of almost diagonal plus almost
anti-diagonal and that's because the
errors when we ran it in a sort of
single qubit mode are largely governed
by capacitive coupling between the
qubits and the device and so most of the
correlation is near nearest neighbor so
we're able to I mean we got the entire
probability distribution so this is just
a summary statistic and there are
correlations beyond just second order as
well we can also do experiments this is
not published yet this is in preparation
with Robin Harper and when Jinyu we can
run this this sparse method using these
data so we've reconstructed using that
original algorithm that I talked about
the entire probability distribution and
I can use that as if it were an Oracle
so we took all that data but we're not
doing those experiments anymore but I
can use that answer as an Oracle to
simulate some more experiments on top of
it so when I add fake noise with
standard deviation so yeah the problem
is I can't point now but if you look at
this graph it has Sigma equals 0.01
Sigma equals 0.005 and so on these are
taking the IBM data set where we
reconstructed everything and adding fake
noise back into that data set and then
running our sparse error reconstruction
protocol and seeing how well it performs
and we see that if I add 0.01 standard
deviation of noise I can reconstruct
faithfully Palli error rates ordered by
probability that's the gray lines there
the gray dots that are kind of hard to
see just look at the blue dots for a
minute I can get error rates down to
about 10 to the minus 4 with about 10 to
the 4 experiments which is 1 over Sigma
squared about okay and so on if you can
do about so we can reconstruct basically
below the signal-to-noise ratio a little
bit because of the fact that there's
favorable averaging when we do this
subsampling and so the point of this
graph is to show that about the maximum
number of experiments you're going to
convince anybody to do is about a
million and that is the the black
crosses and the yellow squares because
the standard deviation is about point
zero zero a woman of course wants to
roughly a million experiments and if you
do that you can estimate error rates
down around the range of about 10 to the
minus 5 using this farce or
reconstruction protocol on a 14 qubit
device so I think that this validates
the sparse reconstruction one in a
pretty practical regime we're very happy
with this and then I'm almost out of
time so my last slide is I just want to
say if you have if we factorize the
noise we can also run this Markov this
is really a busy slide I'm just
realizing that now looking at it up
close we ran a factor graph so I really
wish I had my laser pointer in the on
the top it says it has all the qubits
listed and each of those gray diamonds
is a fact
during a factor graph so we factorized
the error distribution over the factor
graph and although you can't tell very
well from the correlation matrix we
actually capture most of the
statistically significant correlations
using the factor graph using far fewer
parameters once we reconstruct a factor
drak and something like 96 parameters as
opposed to two of the 14 parameters and
it's still very faithful to the original
global estimate so we what we can get is
a much sparser description it still
matches the original global description
using this methodology and there's a
whole lot more in that archived paper
there we did it in two qubit mode and
yeah you can read a lot more about it in
this other paper the yes and what uses
this where we want to go with this is
applying it to something like the Google
device where you know you know 50 cubits
or a hundred cubits in two dimensions it
gets harder to use tensor network
routines in two dimensions but you can
imagine something like the factor graph
on the right so on the left is the graph
of the Google device for their quantum
computational supremacy experiment and
on the right would be a candidate factor
graph that would try to explain nearest
neighbor correlations so we would like
to run something like this next because
if we can characterize the noise we know
you know I just want to plug our paper
that was recently accepted but I David
tuck it it shows that even in the
fault-tolerant saying if we can
characterize noise and things like noise
bias in those correlation we get to see
large increases in the error correction
threshold so that's the vision we can
use all these tools that have been
developed I mean we saw talks by Raman
blue code today Joe emerson there's all
these great methods that have been
developed we can bundle all these
together together with some
post-processing tricks that I described
to do polynomial time reconstruction of
pal annoys I mean once we have that we
hope to do things like Taylor quantum
codes
and optimize the decoders to get
accurate threshold estimation and maybe
optimize entire fault tolerance schemes
based on this information so with that
I'll stop here and thank you for your
attention
thanks Steve it's weird that nobody
claps no clapping you're just going to
hear them okay so maybe so we're gonna
take questions but what people think up
questions that they might want to ask
since this was the last talk of the
workshop I'll hand it over to Henry
who's gonna give like a few closing
remarks and then and and then we'll be
brief and then we take tho the questions
yeah yeah so hi everyone
yeah thanks a lot for tuning in and you
know joining in for this experiment so
you know even though we're all theorists
here we actually just conducted a large
experiment and running a virtual
workshop so congratulations and yeah you
know so I was it's kind of funny like I
was just looking through my emails from
slightly over two weeks ago and you know
it's kind of entertaining to see that we
still thought part of this workshop
would be held in person so I'm sure
everyone can relate to the need to be
quickly adaptable yeah so on behalf of
you know like myself and and other
workshop organizers Thoma dorita harnaam
and yeah alkali I first want to thank
like all the fantastic speakers that we
had during this workshop for continuing
to be very enthusiastic and about
disseminating science and do research
despite all the other distractions that
you might be dealing with and yeah then
I you know I want to give a shout out to
some people behind the scenes first
Ashley Hassan at the Simons is too for
doing one of my shows over event
organization and also drew Mason and
Omid far for setting up a lot of the
technology on short notice and yeah and
then last but not least thanks to all of
you for joining in asking questions and
keeping science going on from home
looking ahead it sounds like the last
time is workshop which is on quantum
devices simulation supremacy and
optimization is full steam ahead and
it's going to be held virtually just
like this workshop so please join us for
that now so that's it thank you very
much
thanks Henry for running a great
workshop Thanks did anybody have any
questions
yeah questions so this is Robin I have a
question but I want to start by saying
also thanks Henry and and thanks to all
the organizers for steaming ahead into
the unknown and making this work so now
question for Steve um this may be a dumb
question but you know as you know that's
my specialty
you talked at the end about running this
on Sycamore so yeah okay the you're
estimating a power channel the gates on
Sycamore are not Clifford's and I don't
know any way to efficiently perform a
circuit that should be an identity so
other than just doing no gates at all it
seems like most of the circuits that I
could do on Sycamore you know if I had
my greasy little fingers on it would be
like highly non-trivial unit Ares what
happens when you run your protocol on
such a channel yeah so that's a great
question that's not a nun question at
all it's a very good question so I mean
there's a few ideas one you could
compile clifford's into it and then
you'd be estimating that compiled the
coarse-grained error rates for the
compiled clifford gate so that would be
an indirect measure you know we do this
all the time I know you're well familiar
with things like interleaved randomized
benchmarking and things like this we
sort of have a reasonable understanding
of how to get
not obviously wrong estimates of
individual things out of collective
things it's surprisingly tricky but that
would be that would be one idea for how
to do it
another idea is to use some of these
ideas there was a paper by Google
actually I forget who the first author
is a number of years ago by now maybe
Kelly or maybe Fowler and Robin Harper
wrote a paper doing tricks like do a
gate and doings inverse these are not
ideal but you can put bounds on things
when you do tricks like this but
basically I would appeal to things like
the same toolkit that you know about
with interleave randomize benchmarking
would be one way that you could envision
doing this yeah or you could you know
tune it up to directly do Clifford gates
but maybe they don't want to do that I
don't know what their plan is going
forward I mean they're going to have to
do Clifford gates at some point if they
want to be quantum error correction in a
service code so they probably want to
know what their Clifford error rates are
let me do that so it's a good question
you
yeah other questions
you
okay if there's no more live questions
maybe we close the workshop thanks
everyone for joining thanks again to
Henry for doing 99.9% of the
organization of the workshop and thanks
to all the speakers for bending their
schedules and making it on time
and online to get the talks so thanks
bye-bye